Transcription: François Fourcault
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vais vous raconter comment
j’ai trouvé la confiance
pour oser réaliser mes rêves d’enfant.
Je suis née à Morteau,
comme il vient de le dire,
dans le Haut Doubs, en 1951.
Ça fait déjà un bail !
D’une famille plutôt bourgeoise,
d’un milieu bourgeois.
Alors vous voyez, cette photo
de mon enfance,
quand je regarde les yeux
de cette petite fille,
ou si vous regardez les yeux
de vous enfant,
on voit dans ces yeux-là tout
ce qu’on est au plus profond.
On voit tous nos rêves, et puis
on voit tous les possibles.
Quand j’étais enfant,
ce que j’aimais, et ce que j’aurais
voulu vivre toute ma vie,
c’était lire, c’était écrire
des histoires dans un cahier,
les inventer.
C’était imaginer des spectacles.
Alors je les donnais dans le jardin de
mes parents, aux gosses du quartier.
Je leur faisais payer un centime
ou un caramel Klaus.
J’avais déjà le sens du commerce,
comme ma mère.
Mais ma mère avait décidé
que je serais institutrice.
C’était son rêve.
C’était son rêve avorté.
Alors on fait quoi de ses rêves d’enfant
quand on a l’impression
qu’on ne pourra pas les réaliser ?
Où est-ce qu’on les enfouit ?
Quelle est la part de confiance qu’il nous
faut pour ne pas les quitter du cœur ?
Comment oser aller les retrouver
un jour et les réaliser ?
Je me rappelle quand, en colonie
de vacances ou à l’école,
on me donnait un rôle
dans une pièce de théâtre,
je me rappelle que j’étais heureuse
et que je me sentais à ma place.
Et quand je lisais un livre
et que le livre m’enthousiasmait,
je sentais que c’était là
qu’était ma place,
c’était là où que je voulais aller.
Mais j’étais programmée
pour être institutrice,
et pour rester dans l’enseignement
jusqu’à la retraite.
Alors comment je vais trouver
cette confiance en moi
qui va me permettre de tout lâcher,
de tout recommencer,
de tout oser ?
Par quel chemin de traverse
la vie va m’emmener ?
Quel chemin vais-je prendre,
quel chemin la vie va me faire prendre
jusqu’à ce que j’arrive à vivre
ma vraie aventure ?
Comment devenir auteure,
comédienne, écrivain
quand on est institutrice ?
Je vais y arriver,
il va y avoir trois connexions
importantes dans ma vie.
Donc, déjà, quand je commence
dans ma première classe,
c’est surtout ne pas enseigner
comme les instits que j’ai eues.
Parce qu’elles m’ont coupé les ailes.
Je n’ai jamais eu l’impression
qu’on m’a aidée à épanouir
ce qui était vibrant en moi,
ce qui était vivant,
ce qui voulait s’épanouir.
Donc, faire tout l’inverse.
C’est-à-dire ne jamais comparer
un enfant avec un autre.
Aider chaque enfant dans ses qualités.
Laisser ceux qui avancent bien avancer,
s’occuper de ceux qui sont en difficulté,
et développer la curiosité, l’autonomie,
l’envie de bien faire, l’entraide,
la démocratie, voter,
décider ensemble des règles,
décider ensemble des textes libres
qu’on va imprimer pour le journal,
trouver des correspondants, faire
une classe vivante comme une ruche,
Eh bien, c’est la pédagogie Freinet.
Et Célestin Freinet a imaginé
cette pédagogie
dans l’école publique
dans les années 1930.
Et donc, pour être encore plus libre
dans cette pédagogie,
je vais choisir une classe unique.
Malheureusement, ça n’existe plus.
C’est une petite école dans un village
où il y a une seule classe
pour accueillir tous les enfants
de la maternelle au CM2.
J’ai à peu près une quinzaine d’enfants,
et je suis nommée aux Arces,
près de Morteau.
La deuxième connexion, c’est que tous
les parents d’élèves sont des paysans.
Je ne connais absolument pas
ce milieu paysan.
Alors je vais souvent organiser
des réunions parce qu’en fait,
il faut que je leur explique que je ne
fais pas la pédagogie qu’ils ont connue.
Il n’y aura pas de devoirs obligatoires,
pas de punitions,
on discute pour régler
les problèmes ensemble.
Alors on fait des réunions,
ils apportent des gâteaux,
on boit la goutte.
Oui, et on re-boit la goutte.
Et je les écoute.
Ils racontent -
ce sont des vrais conteurs -
et je commence à noter leurs expressions
qui me font rire :
« Oh, ce qu’il fait beau hein ?
Oh, et pis c’est parti pour rester ! »
Ou bien : « Oh vous viendrez voir
notre nouvelle cuisine incarcérée ! »
(Rires)
Ou bien : « Elle, elle donnera rien,
elle est radin !
Elle est tellement râteau que quand
elle regarde la messe à la télé,
elle coupe quand c’est la quête ! »
(Rires)
Et aussi : « Vous savez,
quand on voit ce qu’on voit,
et quand on sait ce qu’on sait,
on a raison
de penser ce qu’on pense
et de rien dire ! »
(Rires)
Donc je note, mais je note
pour faire rire mes amis.
Je ne pense pas encore
à ce qui va arriver par la suite.
Je leur demande de venir dans ma classe
pour qu’ils transmettent
leur savoir et leur savoir-faire.
Parce que le savoir-faire des paysans,
c’est énorme.
Ils ont au moins 20 métiers
dans leurs mains.
Ils vont me donner leur confiance.
Parce qu’en fait, les enfants vont être
tellement heureux à l’école,
tellement emballés par les projets
qu’ils vont mener chacun de leur côté
ou en groupe,
qu’ils vont ramener
du travail à la maison.
C’est là que j’ai mis ces parents-là
dans ma poche.
Parce que d’un coup, ils se sont dit :
« Ouah...
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe dans
cette classe avec cette personne ? »
C’est pour ça que je dis toujours
que la Madeleine Proust est née
de la pédagogie Freinet.
La troisième connexion, ça va être
ma rencontre avec Gérard,
Gérard Bôle du Chaumont.
Il est artiste, il entend mes rêves
et lui aussi il me fait confiance.
Il m’entraîne au Conservatoire
d’art dramatique de Besançon.
J’ai 28 ans
et tout va se réveiller en moi.
Aller sur les planches, écrire...
Ça bouillonne.
Je veux créer un personnage,
mais je veux jouer seule
parce qu’à 28 ans, il y a déjà beaucoup
d’années de frustration inconsciente.
Je veux jouer seule,
je veux être seule dans la lumière.
Alors je vais trouver un personnage fort.
Et moi, la comédienne que j’ai vue,
qui m’a impressionnée, c’est Zouc.
C’est une Suisse tout habillée en noir qui
avait fait beaucoup d’asile psychiatrique,
qui avait des personnages
qui entraient en profondeur en nous.
Donc j'essaye une bourgeoise.
C’est un peu le milieu
dans lequel j’ai été élevée.
Ça ne m’intéressait pas trop. Une prolo.
J’essaye une clocharde, une folle.
Et tout d’un coup, j’ai le flash.
Ils sont devant moi.
C’est un trésor que la vie m’a mis là :
le milieu paysan.
Ils sont là, je les vois aux réunions.
Leur accent, leurs expressions,
leurs talents de conteur.
Ils vont être le terreau.
Ils vont être la pâte de ma création.
Je rentre et je dis à Gérard :
« Ça y est, j’ai trouvé !
Je vais faire une paysanne
de 76 ans avec l’accent. »
Il me dit : « C’est ça !
Mais oui, c’est ça ! »
Alors il faut l’appeler Madeleine Proust.
Donc, j’en parle aux paysans,
aux parents d’élèves,
ils me disent : « Nous on n’intéresse
personne, vous savez ! »
C’était dans les années 82, il y avait
énormément de mépris dans les médias.
On entendait rarement
des témoignages de paysans.
Je leur dis :
« Si, moi vous m’intéressez. »
Et donc, comme on l'appelle Madeleine
Proust, il va falloir aller chercher
toutes ces petites madeleines de Proust
et il faudra qu’elles ravivent la mémoire,
qu’elles réveillent le cœur de chacun
et dans chacun un être cher.
Il faudra qu’elle aille puiser
dans les racines de chaque spectateur.
Et grâce aux cinq sens.
Depuis l’odeur de la soupe, qu’on sentira,
jusqu’au son des cloches de vaches
qu’on entendra dans la salle.
Mais alors, comment oser tout lâcher ?
Comment quitter la sécurité de l’emploi ?
Une bonne retraite assurée ?
Qui me ferait dire plus tard, comme
m’avait dit une grand-mère d’élève :
« Moi, depuis la retraite,
j’ai rien à faire
et j’arrive pas à faire
ce que j’ai à faire ! »
Comment oser ? Comment installer
cette confiance en moi ?
On est en 82, j’ai 32 ans.
Alors je vais déjà travailler,
travailler et travailler.
Je vais me lancer à corps perdu dans
un travail de linguistique, d’ethnologie,
de sociologie,
un travail d’écoute sans relâche.
Je vais interviewer une cinquantaine
de femmes, je vais prendre des notes.
Pendant tout ce travail, je n’ai pas
le temps de penser à la peur ou à l’échec.
Mais je vais prendre de la distance
avec les gens négatifs.
Vous savez, ceux qui nous découragent.
Et je comprends en fait que
ma décision de tout lâcher
réveille en eux leur incapacité à oser,
et leur révèle la peur
qu’ils veulent nous transmettre.
Donc il faut vite s'en éloigner.
Il faut se solidifier parce que la peur,
c'est le pire ennemi de la confiance.
D’ailleurs, on voit bien que les gens
de pouvoir, les gens du gouvernement,
ils l’ont bien compris,
comment, avec la peur, ils vont faire
de nous des moutons.
Ils vont nous paralyser, nous ligoter.
Donc, il faut vraiment faire tout
ce travail pour fermer ses écoutilles.
Rester relié à là où on veut aller.
Faire ce spectacle.
Donc il faut que je mette des fondations.
C’est-à-dire que tous les gens
que je vais rencontrer,
les amis, la famille,
les gens dans les magasins,
même des connaissances, des gens
que je ne connais pratiquement pas,
je vais dire tous les jours :
« Je vais faire un spectacle.
Vous viendrez me voir ? »
Dans le magasin de mes parents,
qui vendent des chaussures,
J’en parle à tout le monde.
Comme ça, ça m’oblige à imposer cette idée
et à ne plus, cette fois-ci,
oser la lâcher.
Quand on arrive en 82, je vais
réserver la petite salle de Morteau,
de cent places, et je me dis :
« Il y a mille personnes qui sont venues
voir les Compagnons de la chanson.
Donc il y a mille personnes qui sortent,
donc je la réserve dix fois. »
Ça, c’est mon côté un peu bélier
peut-être, qui va bien me servir.
Et donc, ça y est, j’ai posé
ma décision, je l’ai affirmée,
je l’ai consolidée,
je ne peux plus reculer.
Je travaille, je m’immerge
dans ce milieu paysan.
Je travaille le corps de la Madeleine.
Je travaille sa façon de se déplacer,
le cou en avant.
Toute cette position.
Quel âge ?
J'observe, je note.
Je vais faire un décor, une cuisine
hyper réaliste, puisque je ferai la soupe,
le café,
et je m’aperçois finalement, quand
je suis à fond comme ça dans mon travail,
je m’aperçois que
quand on est dans l’instant présent,
on est libéré de la peur.
Et quand on est libéré de la peur, c’est
qu’on est vraiment dans l’instant présent.
On est dans une énergie qui vibre autour
de nous et on la reçoit, cette énergie.
Donc on reçoit de l'inspiration,
on reçoit des idées.
Mon premier spectacle se passe
dans une cuisine, comme je vous l’ai dit.
Et on connaît le succès qui s’est
passé pendant ces 30 ans.
Le deuxième spectacle, ça a été
une ferme de sept mètres de haut,
avec les quatre saisons,
avec des poules sur la scène.
Puis le spectacle du Tour du Monde que
j’ai créé à la Maison du Peuple à Belfort,
avec de très beaux tableaux,
dont le fameux tableau :
« La Madeleine en patins à roulettes
devant le lion de Belfort »,
pour ceux qui l’ont vu.
Un des compliments qu’on m’a faits,
tout au début à Morteau,
quelqu’un est venu me dire :
« C’est mieux qu’un acteur ! »
Et ça voulait dire que j’avais
tellement incarné ce personnage
qu’on ne voyait pas un acteur qui jouait,
mais qu'on voyait vraiment une Madeleine,
quelqu'un qu'on connaissait.
Et ça, ça a été vraiment...
Ça m’a beaucoup touchée.
Ça a un peu résumé
tout ce qui s’était passé.
Pendant 30 ans, je vais jouer
sur toutes les scènes de France,
pendant des années à Paris,
dans des grands théâtres.
Et quand je ne tourne pas, j’écris.
Je vais publier deux romans,
et puis il m’arrive un cadeau.
Un éditeur me demande d’inventer
une vie à mon personnage,
de lui écrire sa vie.
Et là, c’est tellement extraordinaire,
cette Madeleine que je connais
quand même bien,
que j’ai imaginée, que j’ai inventée,
pour laquelle j’ai déjà trouvé
des points d’achoppement de sa vie.
Là, je vais entrer dans son enfance,
dans ses premières fois.
Et voilà qu’au bout de 300 pages,
je m’aperçois qu’elle n’a que 8 ans.
Alors, j’appelle l’éditeur en lui disant :
« Écoutez, je pense qu’il faudra faire
plusieurs volumes ! »
Et je viens de terminer le tome 3,
ça a mis 10 ans, des tomes de 500 pages.
En fait, mon but,
c’est de battre Marcel Proust
avec ses deux mille pages de
« La Recherche du Temps Perdu », voilà !
En 2018, je fais mes adieux à la scène
pour me consacrer à l’écriture.
Il est grand temps,
comme dirait la Madeleine.
C’est vrai que j’ai quand même
80 ans dans 10 ans, vous voyez.
Et je n’aurais jamais cru que
j’allais être vieille si jeune.
Voilà, moi je pense vraiment
qu’on est sur Terre
pour apprendre à élargir notre conscience,
pour vivre dans l’instant présent.
Pour apprendre à faire la paix
en nous, autour de nous.
Et de transmettre,
c’est notre mission,
c’est ce qui se passe ici.
Alors n’oubliez pas d’être
heureux avec vous-même.
Douze minutes chrono, je les ai dépassées.
Eh bien, comme dirait
la Madeleine Proust :
« Le futur est passé, on ne s’en
est même pas rendu compte ! »
(Rires et applaudissements)
Merci.